imagine if for the first time our heroes
all lost
[Applause]
[Music]
is no place to die
thanos had his way and half of the
population of the universe has gone
everyone's doing their best to keep
their head above water but it's it's
kind of a losing battle we lost and
we're not used to losing people are kind
of still coming to grips with it
natasha is a little bit hardened from
what she's had to go through
they've truly leveled us not just
literally but morally and emotionally
there was no other way
the fans reaction to the end of infinity
war when half their favorite characters
turn to dust really was indicative of
how emotionally connected the world has
gotten to these characters the good
thing is it's always easier to build
people back up after they've been broken
down man that that's what Marvel is
great at doing its that shred of hope
everyone's looking for
I never said no more surprises but I was
really hoping to pull off one last one
[Music]
I like this one
hi everyone it's Charlie we got a brand
new Avengers in game promote to break
down they also released other promos to
give us an idea for who's going to be in
the movie
who's confirmed dead as of the snap and
who's still alive couple cool Easter
eggs in the backgrounds you guys may
have noticed so we got so much stuff
coming up between now and Avengers end
game coming out be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos if you're brand new
to the channel there's new giveaway
stuff I'll explain at the end of the
video too
the footage is mostly them just
explaining where the characters are at
emotionally how everyone's dealing with
things going forward cap basically
telling us that everyone [ __ ] this sort
of explains why they look the way that
they do alt despondent during the
trailer even the scenes where it seems
like they've jumped forward in time
quite a bit where black widows red hairs
grown out and she just looks like she
hasn't been sleeping for the past year
or however long has taken her to grow
that hair out
Captain America looks like he's been
working as a grief counselor because
they transpose the footage of him in
that circle of older military vets while
they're doing Chris Evans portion of
this clip an Iron Man obviously teeing
it all up like what if the superheroes
lost what if we did our Empire Strikes
Back
interesting Easter eggs that you may
notice in the backgrounds of some of
these shots is that you see Iron Man
wearing a shirt that we've never seen
him wear before he's wearing his
infinity war glasses but remember those
are made of nanites so he could just
magic those up anytime he wants during
the sanctum battle at the beginning of
Avengers infinity war he just absorbed
those nanites and repurpose them into
part of his gauntlet so it's not that
surprising that he's burning him again
but he's also sitting inside sharees lab
in Wakanda that has something to do with
a really big Easter egg in another promo
that they revealed where they're talking
about the confirmed dead characters
based on the snap but who we know are
coming back during Avengers endgame so
no surprise that some of this new
information and footage that are giving
us conflicts with some of the other
footage that they've given us you notice
cap is doing his interview and the big
hangar bay of the Avengers facility no
surprise because we've seen him in there
and all the Avengers trailers he's clean
shaven so we know this is taking place
after the events of the Captain Marvel
post-credits scene where we seem in the
trailer because most of the trailer
footage for avengers endgame he's
clean-shaven but in the Captain Marvel
post-credit scene he still has the beard
the clip of Thor is a little deceptive
they could have done this while they
were filming infinity war because it
looks like he's on the set where they
filmed all those big battle scenes
outdoors in Wakanda but the thing is is
that he's wearing the black hoodie
just like he was wearing during Avengers
age of Ultron the hoodie that he's
wearing in the Avengers end game trailer
is a little bit different like he's
dressed down in casual wear people are
wondering why isn't Thor wearing his
armor what's going on that's more
evidence of him just spinning his wheels
not knowing what to do next being
separated from his people and a couple
of other Thor characters from those
movies that we know are coming back now
based on the other promos when you're
watching the trailer footage when the
Avengers start to look a little bit
cleaner like they've actually taken a
shower and cut their hair and put better
clothes on those seemed like more of the
rally points during the film like you
look at Captain America here I mean
obviously he's a clean person but he
just looks like he hasn't been sleeping
then you look at him in the quantum
armor suit which is clearly happening
later in the movie and he seems a little
more clean-shaven his hairs all slicked
back like he's going into battle time
for the big time rally which is why
Chris Evans says during his interview
that it's actually good news that things
are so bad at the beginning of Avengers
endgame which is a funny thing to think
like oh wow it's so awesome that all
those people got dusted but he's just
saying that once you have them hit rock
bottom is so much easier to get people
hyped up about the rally in the rematch
because them losing was something that
they had never done before that was the
big gamble that they were taking even
Kevin Feige said that he was absolutely
sure that they were doing the right
thing with the ending of infinity war
right up until the week before the movie
came out and then he started to question
himself oh my god is this not gonna work
what's gonna happen I mean turns out
everybody hated it but also kind of
loved it at the same time like yes it's
appropriate ending but we're not happy
that it ended this way the footage of
Kevin Feige interview is also happening
in the same place where they did the
Captain America part of that on the
floor of the Avengers base with all the
lights turned down behind them but he's
in an infinity war jacket I think that's
just a coincidence because when he's
referencing the fans reactions to the
end of Infinity Ward he's talking past
tense so this would have had had been
filmed after Avengers infinity war hit
theaters maybe while they were doing
those Avengers endgame reshoots and
pickups moving into the other big promos
that they just released you guys
probably noticed the easter eggs here
what these mean are like all these
posters some of them are black and white
and some of them are in color the ones
that are in black and white Marvel is
saying are dead or dusted because vision
didn't get dusted but he was killed
before Thanos snapped everyone the ones
in color are the ones that are still
alive at the beginning of the movie and
the other thing you
may have realized the other big easter
egg is is that everyone who got posters
is confirmed to be appearing during
avengers endgame at some point
here's the thing though there are a lot
of secondary characters from the other
people's movies we know are going to
appear during at some point that don't
have posters so just because someone
doesn't have a poster doesn't mean
they're not in the movie it's just that
the people that got posters are
confirmed to be in the movie
so confirmed dead spider-man Black
Panther Doctor Strange Groot the wasp
vision Scarlet Witch Gamora Drax Winter
Soldier Falcon star-lord
mantis Loki Nick Fury and of course now
seemingly Shuri I think they're trying
to confirm it but there's a lot of
question about whether or not they're
being misleading because vision is
supposed to come back during the movie
he's the only person that they can
actually repair because he's an Android
he's a machine that they can fix as far
as we know his body is still in Wakanda
Shuri had much better ideas about how to
fix him when they were trying to get the
mine stone out of his body then either
Iron Man or banner had come up with that
means she's probably one of the keys to
fixing vision or giving us the new
version of vision that we're gonna see
during the movie because everyone's
getting a costume redesign they're
getting super hardcore in those quantum
suits stands to reason that a vision
comes back during the film there'll be a
slight tweak to the way his costume
looks also remember that there are other
characters in Wakanda that are still
alive like mbaku is alive at the end of
Avengers infinity war but he didn't get
a poster so there's a lot of characters
like Hank Pym is supposed to appear
during Avengers end game he doesn't have
a poster either so the confirmed alive
characters here are a few surprises
actually too confirming some people that
we didn't know about her in the film the
original six Avengers of course no big
surprise there Ant Man Captain Marvel
nebula war machine in rocket all we've
seen in the trailer so far so that's not
like a real big revelation
Okoye isn't that startling because we
saw her alive at the end of Avengers
infinity war so obviously they had to go
back to Wakanda so Okoye a young Baku
probably gonna be back but here's the
surprises Valkyrie confirmed alive and
we know that she's coming back and she's
gonna appear during the movie because
she got a poster wang is still alive and
he's now the de facto sorcerer supreme
he's the one that's protecting the new
erick sanctum so i've assumed that those
are the members of their order that are
protecting the other sanctums because
they'd be vulnerable to people like
Dormammu
threats from other dimensions Pepper
Potts confirmed alive and obviously
coming back during the movie most people
assumed that she would appear during
this so I don't take it as a huge
surprise happy Hogan is a little bit of
a surprise though so apparently he will
have some role during avengers endgame
so those are all the people that Marvel
is confirming are going to appear during
Avengers endgame but a lot of them as
you saw are dead at the beginning of
that so like Tom Hiddleston's Loki will
appear even though technically he's dead
at the beginning he's dead in
present-day
the Loki that we see during the movie
will at least be the version from the
original Avengers movie when they go
back to that because you seen all those
behind the scenes pictures so they'll at
least be that version of Loki during the
movie wearing his old Avengers costume
there's a lot of questions about what's
happening with Gamora and how they're
gonna bring her back so that she can go
off to the third guardians of the galaxy
movie in the future
way back when infinity war came out last
year I did a couple videos about the
mechanics of the soul gem and how the
soul world works basically a special
dimension that holds a piece of people's
souls after their death the soul gem
preserves life after death but it does
so inside the soul world so a lot of
those people that got dusted are
probably inside the soul gem they've
been a whole bunch of memes too like
there was a daredevil poster someone
made like avenge him there was a goose
poster that boss logic made avenge goose
the cat but what will happen is is the
next couple of weeks before we get
another trailer Marvel would just keep
dropping promos like this so anything
cooled they drop I will totally make a
video for but leave all your Marvel
video requests in the comments below or
we have any big questions or topics that
you want me to do a video about
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video AF kriss77
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here for my new spider-man far from home
promo video and click here for my last
big Avengers and game video where I talk
about what's going on with the Fox
Disney deal thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]